you and you're cutting down just for the
summer or what what's going on here
bikini season man
i want to [ __ ] i want to fight with
some of these youtubers
yeah that's what i wanted dude since
we've met you've been saying that i know
but but it's like who like kenny ko no
come on [ __ ] yeah but
my thing is like these youtubers you
know they're not big dudes like you
like these youtubers are pretty small
kids i don't know who the [ __ ] gonna
fight because here's your problem
a you need somebody who's gonna be your
size which is gonna be tough
yeah b you need somebody who
that's gonna benefit right like you just
fight a nobody because the big dude
it might do well on your channel but if
we want to get this big payday we need
somebody who's going to
compare what clout right that's and
that's the biggest caveat
like there are people that like i could
do it with but it's like
it just it'd be like am i the only one
just driving the sails you know is that
who who's my boy the british guy who
breaks down uh logan paul and stuff like
that
big in mma i love him uh the british guy
true
yeah oh that guy what's up dog
like how big is he he's because he looks
like
the mountain he looks like in the
mountains he's 17 stone
he's not small look at him i met him i
met him in the uk he's 34
six feet six feet wait
there's no way i know that can't be true
yeah no you see me he's gonna be heavier
than that he's
it says he's 198. he's six two there's
no way he's one idea you know this is
all about
six foot there six two somewhere else
come on look at that thick neck
oh damn that's just me going that's just
me spitballing ideas there
yeah similar i want logan paul man yeah
i want to go away i want to fight logan
paul
180. do you have to lose all the weight
but what about true gordy i feel like no
like wouldn't that be i don't know i i
just he does i don't know i mean he does
the podcast stuff i don't know how much
youtube content actually makes you know
i think he's mainly a youtuber i thought
it's all just podcast [ __ ]
he does but he's it's he's like a
youtuber podcaster
he's big in that space i know he's big
as a podcaster i don't know i don't see
much like youtube
i don't know the youtube world i should
stay on that lane podcast for sure i
know i know he's big there
yeah i just don't know but you want
youtuber
yeah i feel like he's a big name and
he's also heavyweight
maybe he'd be down we do a cross you
know pond thing here
we go to the uk just like just like the
ksi and logan paul yeah wait are you
trying to boxer
or mma yeah yeah that's the other thing
like you're a tough seller yeah yeah so
it's like hey
why was that video where you're
literally throwing dudes around the
[ __ ] octagon like
they're going to sleep it's like fight
bradley martin all right boxing
no no he wants to let's do mma they're
like what
i don't want to do that he has almost 2
million subscribers
yeah but it's all podcast content
i get what do you define as podcast
content click on them
like as like there's now just sit down
look the rebuild
that could be you guys dude he he is
every bit of 240. he's definitely not
he's not 198.
who wrote that
me a lot in the next oh he's here and
it's a black british dude i love that
sorry get excited
did you ever fight again no no never
even like this kind of [ __ ]
no i have nothing to gain from this
right because
name a youtuber i don't know youtubers
let's say they came at me and it's like
wasn't he a top 10
heavyweight like and he's picking on
these [ __ ] youtubers like it's not
yeah you'd have to fight it you'd have
to go back and fight a fighter
yeah i'd have to fight like a real like
you already did that like i'd have to
fight like
fedor who's coming out of retirement
that that'd be the only thing where
people like all right
but if i fight like i don't know [ __ ]
the rock that'd be cool
of course but yeah that would be good
but even with the rock nobody's me
cheering for me right
now my mom's like [ __ ] you but you would
beat his ass that'd be cool
that'd be sick but i think he's not
gonna do it no of course not why would
he do that
i would love to fight the rock that'd be
amazing i think thank you christian
i mean i'd hope so but also it's just
like is
are we drug testing what are we doing
here you know like is it just
free-for-all it rocks out and then is it
mma or
mma it's got to be mm-hmm
see i but you're if we're going to do
this man
you're going to have to go with uh what
if you start with box and then we go
from there
because yeah what youtubers gonna fight
your big ass in the mma match
boxing's scary enough then they're gonna
put yeah because i'm thinking about it
i'm like who's gonna who's gonna
you're exactly i'm like dude nobody's
fighting your big ass mm-hmm i'm trying
to i'm trying
to the ground up trying to lose weight
though
what if i fought a real ufc fighter who
was like on his way out
and i had it it would have to be someone
who cut cut from the ufc because ufc is
not going to fight yeah because
because of contracts but for sure that
would be compelling like someone who if
my advantage because obviously i'm not
i'm not a fighter i've never been i've
never fought in ufc ring like you have
right
do you have any background in combat
sports i mean i train yeah i train a
little bit here and there
that'd be no like you like you have idea
like no no wrestling like
no no like actual competitive oh got it
no
so but so if you went after like you
know someone
i'm thinking it's someone who's lighter
than me because my advantage would be my
weight
yep and then they're like actually
really good like a logan paul thing
like his advantage was him being way
bigger yeah like he's not as good as
boxing and obviously that guy's way more
skilled than like in the ufc
yeah so so you've had a light
heavyweight you know somebody probably
walks around at 220 or something
yeah i mean i don't know i don't know
you would know those light heavyweights
are big boys man
like the champion marks probably 240 250
and getting a fight fight yeah we're not
talking about him what about something
like that
yeah 198. i don't know i feel like
somebody be down they're going to hear
this we
probably get some yeah i want to step up
you know
like when you ask me i cannot think of
anybody in that youtube world that would
make sense
yeah i know you want to do it
it'd be cool to fight like isaiah
miranda well that's i mean
like some someone i just think it'd be
cool to see like go in and fight with
like a
like a real fighter in their in their
actual sport because all these guys like
they're trying to like
you know jake paul's they take the
people out they've been thinking about
and fighting them now
yeah i mean even even tyrone like it's
now it's like leave ufc box me
yeah right yeah i want to i want to see
someone like go in that actual sport and
try it
obviously you need some they need some
sort of advantage because like they
don't have the amount of hours that that
guy's had in the ufc ring like this
they're
they're completely brand new to it and
you're advising this
yeah no is that not a good one
um yeah the advantage would be size
obviously not the actual fighting
experience have you talked about it on
your channel before has anybody
no this is the phone and i'm like i'll
thank you and then i'm like
yeah we keep talking about it i i just
it's just yeah it's like in your head
i just like i think because like yeah
why not like also because
these other guys logan and them and they
like i said they take the fighters out
of their like
they're actually what they killed yeah
fight them somewhere else where they
know they obviously have a better chance
like i get it like i understand the
whole game you're willing to
be cool to see someone like do some [ __ ]
that's you know fight them
obviously in what they're good at and my
idea was like oh
be heavier though that would be my
advantage yeah can you think of anyone
chin
bradley has size but not on the way out
though right
like even smaller smaller but on the way
out of size
henry cejudo okay
what buy him small because he's retired
he's really small
he's retired super small super small but
you're talking about an olympian and a
two-time
two-division world-class champion well
mike perry
yeah but you mentioned mike perry before
my parents are someone crazy
perry's a good one do it no not anymore
not anymore yeah lucy won't let him
touch it that's why dana threatened it
when like
logan was like oh i want khan or
something like that dana's like not
happening dude
quit chasing after my [ __ ] guys like
we're gonna sue you if you continue
really yeah yeah oh [ __ ] ufc does not
play that game i don't know it can't be
someone
has to be someone retired isn't that
crazy though because i'm sorry
interrupting
ufc like it started like completely odd
fights
like the big guys you know for sure
fighting styles
but but you got to make it a sport like
you have to be a sport let's be weight
classes
yeah otherwise it's just a freak show
but for yours we want a freak show
yeah that's why henry's the hood makes
sense and i know you really do you
really think it's
racist how old how he's 20 30.
he's so little but he's so talented
if we want to get like old-school ufc
style like
you're talking about like ufc
then the other question is does he does
he like would he drive enough
traffic to it i think so if i dude take
all my [ __ ] money if you fought henry
oh yeah well that's what you're saying
right now to me but i'm saying would he
would would that just be me son
or what like does he have an audience to
sell that too he has an odd in the
fight audience to get behind him you're
talking about ufc royalty yeah they love
him
chocolate doubt no
god we love children yeah what about
anderson silva oh my god bj fan would be
a crazy
crazy it would be a show